[Music]
I think this team's legacy is huge the
Muslim girls basketball team that's
dominating they're proud of their faith
and they wanted a part of their story a
lot of those girls probably don't think
that they are representing something
bigger than themselves their high school
kids how unfair is it for them to have
to take that responsibility and do it so
well every single day they've totally
shifted the communities and now even
maybe a national idea of what this team
can be and then all Muslim team can be
[Music]
[Music]
I've been playing basketball since
seventh grade
my older brother played basketball and I
went to a lot of his games so my dad was
like you know why don't you try them we
go out there and we represent more than
just a basketball team we represent our
religion represents a lab school we
represent girls
I feel like some people do have negative
image about us Muslims they downgrade us
even though we're like normal people you
know we're out there like normal people
we play like normal people freshman year
we were kind of joke almost the students
would say why would we go to one of
their games we would never really have
any support we took that negativity to
like positivity our record right now
we're tolling for the girls programs
only been around for how long I think is
fine like backing back to last year or
two years ago you guys are just all over
the place but now everybody's on the
same page and you guys are just rolling
you got a good possibility coach
honestly you know they went through like
a bunch of coaches just never worked out
and she just came out of nowhere
I came like the first day of practice
and I was like oh my gosh we need to
practice every day I'm gonna schedule
more games more scrimmages we just need
to be around basketball more I saw the
talent the girls had but just like they
weren't playing enough every coach I've
ever had since I was in third grade has
been a man so for me a female coach and
coaching a female team I thought it was
pretty cool and I don't know how much
the first two years that they even
picked up on how different that is have
a female coach there's not many our
coach always tells us does it matter
what the score is as long as we clear
heard it's like very good we're always
pushing for the best you know she always
says think of the controllables
sometimes the shots just don't fall in
so she always says play defense well
move your feet focus on controllables
sometimes I don't even have to coach
because they know exactly what they
should be doing I would definitely
describe how we play as aggressive most
people you know maybe wouldn't think
that we play aggressively but yeah
definitely aggressive I think they're a
little bit underestimated and I would
say that in general of the Muslim team's
that's played over the times in
Milwaukee I think that other teams are
kind of surprised when they're warming
up you can tell like oh they're like
looking at us while we're shooting or
whatever and they're like just joking
around or they're laughing or not or not
and coach always tells us to she's like
hey look they're not taking you
seriously it is like a secret weapon
I'm going to be going we put all our
effort in and we come out then the
surprise
they think probably play wearing the
scarf I never really knew girls can play
like this and especially Muslims
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there are people who are like against us
you know playing basketball
[Music]
we definitely get a lot of stares and
they're thinking like oh there's
actually Muslim girls that play
competitively people see just like a
religion first because obviously we're
wearing this carbs
there's always stereotypes that are
gonna be thrown around
[Music]
they'll be like oh there were scarves
because they're oppressed and stuff like
that
I mean in my family where I grew up it
was always like the same between like
equal between all my brothers and me
[Music]
honestly I love wearing a scarf and I
love my religion I don't have a problem
with wearing it while I play and I don't
feel uncomfortable I don't feel hot I
think right now it gets good that they
say that were Muslim girls basketball
team to kind of create that
normalization or like oh look at these
Muslims it's not an article about them
doing something wrong doing so or not
and said it's an article about them
doing something great and then
empowering maybe one day we'll come to a
time where that title will be dropped
like we don't let it get in the way we
actually like try to work harder just to
break those stereotypes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as a senior I think about my
relationship with my teammates and how
close we've gotten basketball is just
like us this is it
[Music]
[Applause]
is anything spicy as this spicy white I
didn't make spicy but for me is not
spicy
so I see the brackets camo I'm kind of
surprised a bit so a lot of school is
rated 15th in the brackets yeah
last Saturday I don't know if you guys
know this but I go to a seedy meeting up
in Sheboygan and all the coaches in that
region come in with their season
summaries you sit down and you vote
where you should think you should be
seated when we went in we were 11 and 4
just screaming out some numbers out of
15 what seed do you think you guys
should have been and no second 11 anyone
else at 7 I would agree somewhere in the
middle right all the teams voted us last
yeah and I was like we're last are you
kidding me why are you voting this way
because I need to know because if it's
strength of schedule we beat teams that
you have lost to it were rated last and
but there's teams with one or three wins
that was it behind them my opinion is
we've always been last they've always
voted us last that's like a cowardly
thing to do where they don't have to
worry about us honestly as a voice if we
had a 14 and 4 season which we don't we
would be we would be very very like we'd
probably be at least a third I feel like
it's just a bias towards them yeah so we
play the number 2 seed in the region on
Tuesday Catholic Central so don't let
that unfairness dictate how you play
[Music]
[Music]
are you guys feeling a little bit of
added pressure than any yeah they're the
second seed they're expected to win
right we already know that come out
strong with intensity and never let up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
on the quarry there's controllables you
can control boxing out you can go to a
hall while you play you cannot control
the other team you cannot control the
referees and same thing in life you can
control what you choose to do in a
certain situation but you cannot control
other people's think you cannot control
how they will look at you it's just how
life works here you guys have come like
crazy fire I'm proud of you guys the
whole season you had and regardless of
the tonight's score that doesn't reflect
who you guys are as players that team
was supposed to be the number one seed
in the region so pretty monumental task
to take down the number one seed in the
region right yeah so you guys played
hard and I'm really proud of you guys
I'm proud of you try to me
I'm trying to create a culture here
where the girls the basketball team
isn't a joke no one came to their games
they always lost they didn't care about
them and now with them winning they wear
their backpack tags their sweat suits
they have a pride in their program
everyone else in the school in the
community it also has that bright now
it's not just about like winning the
score you know if I get this many
rebounds the biggest thing I want them
to take off the court is being a
confident woman don't let anyone tell
you who you should be or how you should
act you be who you are because you're
confident who you are I am really proud
to go out and play competitively be one
of the only competitive with some girl
teams in America playing I love you guys
all right two more than the score
[Applause]
I appreciate all the alumni coming back
you guys have definitely helped build a
program here I really appreciate you
guys putting the hard work and
dedication every year so I hope you come
back and show that what it means to be a
sponsor so bring it in
all right what's the cheer what are we
saying
[Music]
I've been really cute so yeah I'm very
proud I said that's what I do
she's pretty tall she's pretty athletic
so who's gonna match up with her you
guys ready
all right let's tip it off
[Music]
I feel bad I don't want to take any of
them out
who wants a sub
you sure okay it sounds like one of the
things we might have in common is some
naysayers right it's not something that
as a woman's professional athlete sadly
we face all the time
whether it's the stupid comments on
Twitter telling us to stay in the
kitchen or it's just people who put us
down or try to compare us to our male
counterpart and it's tough I mean I
think it's okay to feel bad about that
and then realize know what somebody else
thinks with me doesn't mean anything
[Music]
thank you guys so much just had a great
time at the salon school with the alumni
game I don't know about you guys but I
got buckets and I'm an official super
fan thanks Rob
[Music]